hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the food and drug administration's
advisory committee greenlighting
pfizer's covet 19 vaccine
clearing the way for the agency's
leaders to authorize emergency mass
distribution amid an ongoing surge of
virus cases
across the nation but how long will a
return to normalcy take
fox business anchor liz clement
discusses the timeline for businesses in
the u.s to recover from the pandemic
and what she says lawmakers in
washington should do to support
struggling industries while the election
was over a month ago
americans remain divided over the
results nearly 75 percent of republicans
in a recent poll
say they do not accept president trump's
defeat fox news sunday host chris
wallace weighs in
on the trump administration's election
legal challenges and whether he thinks
americans will agree
on taking a coronavirus vaccine plus
commentary from jimmy fayla
host of fox across america the fox news
rundown is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm jerry willis i'm steve ducey i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
friday december 11th 2020 i'm lisa brady
a cobit vaccine clears a major hurdle
and it may be the way out of the
pandemic
but there will be scars on the u.s
economy even
more upsetting is all the small
businesses you've never heard of
they don't have the big names and they
are not coming back
i'm chris foster the election's been
over for weeks and as president trump
and his supporters keep fighting the
results americans seem as politically
divided as ever
look i'm not sure anybody can bring the
country back together again
we talked to fox news sunday host chris
wallace and i'm jimmy fella i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
the vote was overwhelming a panel of fda
advisors recommending approval of
pfizer's covet 19 vaccine in the u.s
17-4 with one abstention thursday
evening
after a day-long hearing that concludes
the vote
so we do have a favorable vote the final
decision is up to career staff
at the fda which is widely expected to
follow the recommendation
britain was first to use the vaccine
with only a few issues reported in this
week's
uk rollout people who had an allergic
reaction
what we were told from the uk is these
were two individuals who are very
hypersensitive hyper allergic the kind
of person that needs to go around with
an epipen
white house task force member admiral
brett gerard telling fox news that data
will be studied and could prompt an
advisory for certain
people to defer getting the shot for now
as the fda weighs emergency
authorization
covet cases continue to set records
across the u.s
on wednesday over 3 100 deaths
more than on 9 11 or d-day in world war
ii
on thursday the nationwide total passing
290 thousand lives lost and climbing
the virus has also killed tens of
thousands of businesses
a hundred and ten thousand american
restaurants
have already permanently shut their
doors house minority leader kevin
mccarthy says about one in five
small businesses have shut down house
speaker nancy pelosi agrees the need for
help
is urgent and wants a deal before
christmas week when enhanced
unemployment benefits expire
now if we need more time then we take
more time but we have to have a bill
and we cannot go home without it but for
now a
months-long debate over another covent
relief bill
continues in the meantime though wall
street has also been setting records
new highs fueled in large part by light
at the end of the tunnel
the hope for vaccine success they say
that the market
usually runs about six months ahead
of the economy or news that's happening
so the optimism
is is very much entrenched at the moment
liz clayman is host of the clayman
countdown on fox business
and the everyone talks to liz podcast i
mean we have had multiple records over
the past
couple of days depending on the day and
it just appears to me that
wall street looks at these numbers when
it comes to the vaccine
they know it's there they know it's a
matter of time canada and the united
kingdom are already distributing it
and therefore they think well let's run
ahead
about six months when lots of people
hopefully will have been vaccinated
that's a key question though because it
seems like a significant percentage
of americans might not be ready to get
vaccinated
how big a concern is that especially for
businesses
it's a very big concern last numbers i
saw
60 percent say they'll take it 40
percent are still
on the fence about it and some of those
people are actually
first responders maybe firefighters
police officers
i think that once they see that there is
a wave
and the positive aspects that come out
of that wave
regarding the economy you know all roads
lead to people's wallets
and of course their hearts i mean you
know we've lost so many people over this
do you really want to take that chance
and lose more it's really
stunning given how many how many months
it's gone on and
how new and bleak it was back in march
when things
really shut down at the beginning what's
it gonna take for the economy
to fully recover from this i mean is it
equal parts
everything being open and people being
comfortable going into all those places
or is there something more incremental
that needs to happen that's an excellent
question
the easy answer would be when everybody
gets vaccinated
not necessarily i would put it like this
and there are people who would
completely disagree with me
but i am keeping my eye on two sectors
the arts and restaurant chains
when you see them come back when they
are fully allowed to reopen
indoor and outdoor dining that's for the
restaurants and people actually
go you will see a revitalization
and it's interesting that i bring up the
arts because a lot of people roll their
eyes and say wasn't that sort of squishy
no
no no the arts means movie theaters
live venues arenas
broadway theaters all over the place
you know that anything arts related with
the music industry movies television
theater
equals about 4.5 of gdp
in this country 4.5 that's more than
transportation
that's more than agriculture so once
those come back to me
that will be the signal that the economy
truly
truly is coming back because all those
people who've been laid off a million in
the arts community
close to a million or maybe even more in
the restaurant industry
once they're rehired then you can start
to breathe a little easier
i know you interviewed the ceo of airbnb
on the claimant countdown as they were
making their nasdaq debut
and he seemed to have an optimistic
outlook
you know despite having taken a really
big hit from the pandemic shutdowns
you know i i this company was born in a
crisis in the crisis of 2008
and you know we couldn't afford to pay
our rent and i think that you know you
have to have optimism
even in your darkest days you have to
believe that things will eventually get
better
that these are moments in time airbnb
just
endured a near death experience
when you lose 80 percent of your
customers
in one day okay collapse
you don't survive that he managed to
survive
in fact brian chesky said uh few people
have survived and lived to tell
losing 80 of their business their
customers
but here's what they found they found
that you immediately start plugging the
holes
you do what you have to do and some of
that is painful they had to lay off
1 900 or 25 of their employees
okay just to save the business so that
one day down the road
they would be able to hire them back and
then they started to see
the silver lining effect and that was
that if people
were going to work from home they
realized they could work from anywhere
and if you're going to work from
anywhere heck instead of being stuck in
a little one-bedroom walk-up in
on the lower east side why not go to a a
yurt
in indonesia or go to canada and sit in
a cabin
and look at look at vancouver bay i mean
there's so many things that you could do
and that was socially distanced
opportunity for him and he started to
see that
so yeah that was an interesting
interesting business case
and at some point that will be a harvard
business school case study
of how they survived this
very interesting i mean contrast that
with a company like
doordash which also started trading this
week
um they did very well with a spike in
food delivery during the pandemic
so there's one of they're one of the
companies that sort of had a silver
lining
in the middle of it but could they
suffer a setback
when things go back to quote-unquote
normal or whatever that is
doordash and doordash bulls are probably
banking on a new normal and they're
thinking
nobody will ever go out again or they
will severely attenuate how many
times they go to a restaurant and
therefore their business will be
awesome here's the thing about doordash
and who knows
i think it's a phenomenal business it
works very very well
however if ever they were going to have
the best year ever this is it people
were
locked down so they had to find a way to
get delivery
doordash emerges as this
you know this incredible moment the sun
bursting out we're here to save you
and they kept people employed they're
very smart they've struck a
lot of relationships with restaurants
and now they're striking relationships
with pharmacies
and big box retailers saying we're not
just gonna doordash or deliver
food we can deliver a lipstick if
somebody's desperate
spoken like a true you know television
news anchor who sometimes is desperate
for a lipstick to be delivered but
seriously i think that they'll do okay i
just think that that's a big question
mark hanging over them
what other industries saw a boom from
this
and could suffer when it ends i feel
like there's a lot of
sort of question marks hovering out
there well let me give you one that
won't suffer
i think a new normal definitely has
bestowed
a lot of shining light on telemedicine i
think telemedicine
is a business that people were
suspicious of in the past
wait the doctor can't really see the
rash that i have
telemedicine is brilliant and it works
and my goodness i used it just to get
approval to get a vaccine
and i can tell you i was so impressed
i think that's a business that will do
very well
well after the pandemic i am very
worried about commercial real estate
commercial real estate has gotten
hammered because people
work from home and then companies
realize wait
why are we spending all this money to
rent 22 floors
in midtown manhattan downtown la
san francisco when a good portion of
these employees
are doing as good a job and they're
actually happier
with that work life balance and working
from home maybe we can cut that down to
10 floors
or four floors i think that that is
going to be a question
that is a big overhang for commercial
real estate
now the malls are interesting the malls
figured out quickly what are we going to
do they immediately started
opening up some of their empty space to
amazon
amazon started taking empty anchor
stores like jcpenney
in these malls and turning them into the
warehouse distribution areas for them
they got a discount i mean listen
there's nothing like striking a deal
when nobody wants the product
this is brilliant so i i think that if
you're malleable
and you are quick on your feet and you
bend so you don't break
those are industries that will stay
alive
do we have any more of a sense now about
whether all of this
working from home is likely to continue
or does it become
more likely the longer it goes on
i don't know i i miss being in the
office
i don't love the commute of going to the
office
but i'd like to go back for the the the
simple reason of working face to face
with my team
and i i think zoom has saved us
obviously but
if you are somebody who loves
collaboration
it's much easier to do it spitballing in
a room with a whiteboard and you get to
all do it and you're there and then you
can run into somebody's office
there are other industries though that
will be just fine
where the people have decided you know
what we could work from home
but when you tick off all of the big
names
gold's gym friendlies j crew neiman
marcus
true religion genes pier 1 cirque du
soleil
they all file for bankruptcy that
doesn't mean that they'll disappear
forever because you know you can do
bankruptcy protection and reorganization
etc
but consumer demand just dropped off for
them and that's extraordinarily sad but
even
more upsetting is all the small
businesses you've never heard of
they don't have the big names and they
are not coming back
when they go under it's just a leviathan
effort to reopen
and that will be a scar that takes a
long time to disappear on this economy
but the coveted relief bill that they're
still talking about in congress i mean
is that is it too late for that to
you know help businesses significantly
while they wait for the vaccine
not too late it's a disgrace that it
hasn't come yet
it's a disgrace that we are waiting up
to the deadline before
congress gets up and leaves to go home
so they can quarantine and then have
their holiday
family events this is really important
this is their job to pass this thing
there is that bipartisan bill
why not just go for it cut with the
politics
don't let the perfect be the enemy of
the passage
i just find it really really distressing
that they're still arguing over this
as people literally lose their jobs and
close their businesses
day after day after day
liz clayman host of the clayman
countdown thank you very much for your
time
[Music]
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
the presidential inaugurations in 40
days president trump says he should be
the one standing there
being sworn in for a second term saying
monday during a presidential medal of
freedom ceremony
you look at the different states the
election was totally rigged
it's a disgrace to our country it's like
a third world country these ballots
pouring in from everywhere using
machinery that
nobody knows ownership nobody knows
anything about they have
glitches as they call them glitches the
glitches weren't glitches they got
caught
sending out thousands of votes all
against
me by the way and polls show a majority
of republicans say they do not accept
that joe biden really won
he ran as the candidate to bring america
together you know you've gotten
president trump refusing to acknowledge
that he won and
continuing these lawsuits uh and
pressuring the state legislators and
pressuring members of congress
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday had this run
like a normal transition with the
president
inviting the president-elect in uh and
inviting
members to the oval office uh
starting the transition and letting
biden team members go into the various
agencies
uh we have a different feeling i you
know i
i will say biden uh has made some
choices in in the cabinet that i think
are uh are going to be pretty
difficult to get through and that
certainly doesn't doesn't add to that i
mean the choice of near attendant to be
the budget director
uh lloyd austin general austin uh a
distinguished military person
uh former retired but you know you're
gonna have to have a waiver again and
there's gonna be a big argument
about that uh look i'm not sure anybody
can bring the country back together
again i mean we're so
polarized and you can see it with
biden's appointment some of them
are getting i mean literally uh here at
tandon
who i'm sure most people don't know she
was the head of the center for american
progress
uh a liberal think tank she's getting
hammered by
both by the right and the left from the
right that she's too liberal from the
left that she's too much a a a too tied
to big corporate interests so
you know it's awfully hard for anybody
to bring
this country together these days i mean
this is still very very much
donald trump's republican party i mean
if you as a republican
question or deny that the election was
rigged you're risking your political
life
absolutely and and that's one of the
reasons
why so many people that privately
in congress will say to you well of
course the election's over and of course
these
uh the this delayed transition and the
president's refusal to acknowledge the
election
and the continued lawsuits are bad for
democracy we'll say that in private
they won't say it in public because at
this point unless you're
mitt romney or somebody who's out there
and you know so clearly on the record
as not being in the trump camp you you
don't you can't risk this i mean go ask
uh bob corker or jeff flake what about
what taking on this president
does to your political future the answer
is you don't have any
do you think that that influence will
last from the sidelines with his social
media whatever other media he gets
involved with not to mention
the potential of another run in 2024.
well
i think that at least initially that
uh and i've talked to some people who
are thinking of running for president
in 2024 it freezes the field there is
nobody you know and you can talk about
from mike pence to
tom ted cruz tom cotton nikki haley
nobody is going to come out
as early as they might have if the
president were acting differently
and say you know of course i'm thinking
about 2024 because
again you know to do that
it's not only that you uh antagonize
president trump
uh and run the risk of some mean tweets
uh
you also antagonize the millions of
people that consider themselves
part of the trump base right and you
know what whether or not trump
actually runs in 2024 i don't know he
doesn't know
you know a lot happens in four years uh
right now that's not a fight you want to
take on 100
is back in the news the
president-elect's son um
under federal investigation for some
financial stuff that's not what joe
biden wants to be taking up bandwidth
as he tries to bring americans on board
no
um and you know one of the things that's
interesting and i think you're going to
see
uh you know the mainstream media maybe
pay a little bit of a price for this
they
they didn't cover some would say they
covered up but they certainly didn't
cover
the the uh the allegations
against joe biden in in the fall you
know before the election
uh and i i think that they deserved at
least some coverage do i think that
you know there was some over coverage
absolutely but i think it deserves some
coverage and in some places it seemed
like it got none
at all so for people who were just
relying on those news sources this story
came out of nowhere that suddenly
joe biden has these these foreign
business dealings and it's under
investigation and there's been a grand
jury empaneled
uh and the u.s attorney in delaware i
you know we don't know
i mean all of that is a long way away
from a charge
from an indictment uh and you know some
people are now rushing to say well
you know and what does this how does
this implicate the the president-elect
uh there's no indication so far that
he's either a subject or a target
the president elected this investigation
so you know we have to wait and see
but clearly this is a news story and i
think a lot of people
were ill-served because they this is the
first they've heard about this news
story
yeah i mean and this is like you said an
actual grand jury this isn't uh you know
a laptop
with some this is this isn't as murky as
is the stuff we got in the fall now no
the fact that the fact that is that the
you know the us attorney's office in
delaware formally notified if you
believe
hunter biden is the one who actually
announced it uh
formally notified biden that they are
investigating him he's either the
subject or the target
of an investigation so that's that's
legit at this point doesn't mean he's
going to be charged but it's a
legitimate news story
by this time next week some coronavirus
vaccines
will probably be in some people's arms
uh
pretty great is a scientific achievement
a quarter of americans though
according to some polls are saying no
thanks it's not for me
uh so part of the work besides the
distribution of the vaccine is going to
be convincing enough people to take it
absolutely and and you know my guess is
actually i've seen numbers as high as 40
percent of americans say they
either won't or may not take it i i
think that changes
over time in other words there's been a
lot of talk about this being tied into
into politics was were corners caught
the operation warp speed did
you know was there a political rush to
try to get it approved
you know you're going to get people that
that are probably almost
100 going to take it health care workers
people in nursing homes now
and you know in a month or two when we
see one whether they've gotten immunity
and two whether there have been any
serious side effects
i think a lot of people who are now
either on the fence or
saying no will change their minds about
it but there's no question that part of
this
is not the distribution effort is not
just going to be getting the vaccine out
it's also going to be public service
announcements and you know
major public figures like former
presidents taking the vaccine
to say look this is safe it's effective
take it yeah layoffs are back to what we
had in september
where does a relief package stand well
yeah we're back over 800 000 very
concerning this this
is an economy that's got real problems
got real problems from unemployment real
problems from
businesses that are just hanging on by
their fingernails
uh the eviction moratorium runs out the
end of the year
i mean we need coveted relief um you
know
when we were talking a week ago it
seemed that
these uh this this gang of eight a
bipartisan group four republican
senators for democratic senators
had come up with something and they did
come up with something the problem is
that you know every time you put your
foot out there
you know into the water put dip your toe
in the water somebody wants to chop it
off because the republicans are saying
no it needs to be less money
where democrats are saying it needs to
be more money they're arguing about the
policy components like liability
protection uh aid to
cities and states in the bill the white
house is now saying well
don't give extra unemployment benefits
give the 600
lump sum payment um i don't know
i mean it it the the need for this seems
overwhelming
and congress's ability to ignore
and fail to meet that need seems uh
irresistible so i don't i don't know how
this gets resolved
uh i sure hope they come up with
something yeah i mean we see all these
stories
uh fox has been featuring a lot of
restaurant owners for example and other
business owners who are
uh either protesting or flat out
breaking coronavirus restrictions but
these
there seems to be more protests against
shutdowns and restrictions
than there are people pushing congress
to help them yeah well uh
because you can understand i mean
getting on tv and saying that they're
killing me
here by shutting down my business and
you know that story in california
where a woman has a small restaurant and
they're telling her that she has to shut
down and right across the street
they're making a movie and they've set
up a tent with the outdoor commissary
so that all the people can be fed
outdoor dining it doesn't seem any
different than the outdoor dining she
was doing
you know that's a pretty that's a pretty
strong story and that obviously
has more legs than somebody calling
members of congress and saying you know
vote for this bill um you know i
i i'm a very mixed feelings here on the
one hand i i feel terribly
you know i in my local community
we're very close to people who own a
restaurant and they've had to open and
shot and open and shut
and you know we're very close to these
people and and you know
they've spent years building up this
business and they're hanging on by their
fingernails so i feel
very upset about it and and and very
empathetic towards them and their plight
and i don't know what the right answer
is about what needs to stay open what
you know and the science is changing now
it appears that particularly for
elementary school
having schools open and letting kids
stay in if they're safer there than they
are
out in the regular world the outside
world
uh what about indoor dining outdoor
dining
i think we have to tread very lightly
but clearly
you know the spread of the virus of 200
000 cases
you got to address that as well chris
wallace host of fox news sunday thanks a
lot talk to you next week
yes sir thank you chris
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
a chicago second grader is proof that
anyone can make a difference
no matter their age haley orlinski is
seven and she's spent the better part of
the pandemic making bracelets out of
rubber bands and it's not just a hobby
haley sells the bracelets as a
fundraiser to buy personal protective
equipment for a children's hospital
so far it's generated nearly twenty
thousand dollars for anne and robert h
laurie children's hospital
her initial goal was two hundred dollars
which she
quickly surpassed charging three dollars
a bracelet or
five for one with a charm added it
started when she heard about ppe
shortages during the pandemic and she
was inspired to help
her mother children's book author
laurier linsky
estimates the effort has created roughly
eight thousand bracelets
most of them made by haley the
fundraiser has been a family project
a four-year-old sister helps organize
the bands by color and both parents help
mail the finished products nationwide
her high-profile donors include chicago
mayor lori lightfoot
and haley was even recognized by the
white sox at a ball game
haley's experience in sales isn't just
limited to bracelets
she also has sold the most cookies in
her girl scout troupe
she says she's got no immediate plans to
stop making bracelets
which means she'll be making a
difference for a while to come
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fala
what's on your mind sports illustrated
named the activist athlete as its sports
person of the year
now with all due respect to the
outstanding men and women on the list
asking fans to salute woke athletes is
the worst business proposition i've ever
heard in sports
and i say that as someone who has once
offered season tickets to the new york
knicks
to be clear the sports person of the
year is a lot like the mcrib
in that it gets a ton of hype when it
first comes out but everybody forgets
about it a few days later
perhaps for their own good in the case
of the mcrib what sets this year's award
apart is that s.i is celebrating
athletes for what they did off the field
instead of what they did
on it ushering in a new era in which
batting stances take a backseat to
political stances
in theory it's commendable that athletes
want to affect positive change
but in reality it's killing ratings and
the badly needed escapism that sports
used to provide us with
viewership for this year's nba finals
were down 51 percent from 2019
because the vast majority of fans they
don't put on a game to solve societal
problems
they put it on to get away from them
there was a time when sports represented
a form of common culture in this country
a place where people could put their
political differences aside for a few
hours a night
take in a game and have a beer they
might even gamble
either with a bookie or by eating the
stadium nachos
those days are long gone and i take no
joy in saying it because this country
would greatly benefit from the awesome
superpower that pro sports have to unite
us
in the face of adversity think of
president george w bush throwing out the
greatest first pitch in history
prior to game three of the 2001 world
series at yankee stadium
which of course was just weeks after the
september 11th attacks
nobody cared about politics in that
moment nobody cared who you voted for
when bush took the mound because players
in that era recognize that while not
perfect america is the greatest source
of good the world has ever known
and for that alone we should be able to
unify for three hours a night to watch
them earn their millions
while we blow our thousands on hot dogs
and beer does anybody on the sports
person of the year list honestly believe
the country
is more unified as a result of their
activism this year
if so you should check them into the
concussion protocol program right away
and again i'm not telling athletes to
quit the fight but i am telling them to
move the battlefield
because the most iconic sports moments
in history the ones that will stay with
you forever
they have two things in common one is
they all have nicknames like the catch
and the shot heard around the world and
the miracle on ice
the other is that none of them are
political statements
sports illustrated will score plenty of
points with the social justice crowd for
their salute to activism
but if leagues keep running this play it
may lead to another historic sports
moment
called the chapter 11. be sure to check
out fox across america with me jimmy
fallon weekdays from noon to 3
on foxnewsradio.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes